le Mouvement Démocrate est un mouvement
à taille
[Musique]
humaine je m'appelle Anice moidel j'ai
36 ans je suis né à audiou dans le Var
après des études de droit à la fac de
toulomb puis à la fac d'exen Provence
j'ai été juriste d'entreprise au sein
d'un cabinet d'experts comptable
aujourd'hui je suis attaché
parlementaire et depuis 2017 pour un
député MoDem Mohamed lakila mon parcours
militant a commencé très tôt c'est
depuis 2012 lorsque je me suis suis
rendu compte que la plupart de notre
jeunesse n'avait absolument plus
confiance en la politique j'ai alors
décidé de m'engager à un niveau local
pour me rendre utile d'abord et
aujourd'hui je suis conseiller municipal
depuis 2015 pour la commune de Bandol
suite aux élections municipales
partielles qui sont intervenues en
décembre 2015 notre liste a de nouveau
été élue je me suis vu confier la
délégation de la politique en faveur de
l'emploi et la première des choses que
j'ai constaté c'est que les entreprises
bandolaises étaient beaucoup trop
éloigné des demandeurs d'emploi bandolé
fort de mon expérience politique et
cherchant à trouver une famille
politique avec des valeurs et un
engagement qui soit sincère j'ai rejoint
dès 2018 le Mouvement Démocrate le
Mouvement Démocrate d'abord un mouvement
qui a des idées qui sont pour moi en
équilibre ni trop de droite ni trop de
gauche c'est ce que la politique aurait
dû être depuis toujours le Mouvement
Démocrate est par ailleurs un mouvement
à taille humaine c'est-à-dire que lors
de certaines runion militante lors de
certains événements publics on se
retrouve tous ensemble des pontes des
moins connus pour discuter de choses
réelles de la vie
quotidienne